house gone brass - prayer - back so it's
been a while since we played some sexy
games I can't remember any time we
played a sexy game some people would
argue this game is not sexy at all and
today at to them I say you have no taste
in men women I did what this is gonna be
kinky so if you're not into kinky stuff
you shouldn't be watching my videos to
be honest ok here we go
it's made by yeah if you can read cactus
is now famous for making hot male on
Miami and I can't speak so they gave it
a hot throttle it's a racing game let's
do a tournament why aren't you wearing
any clothes why is he so [ __ ] sweaty
can you hear me I don't I don't think ok
I've said why aren't you wearing any
clothes super piss cars don't wear
clothes cars cars don't talk
is he right up I don't know kind of
[ __ ] position is there Oh Joey so
there you go it's a game about naked
people thinking that their cars running
around and straight it's really
difficult
I cannot beat this game cactus cactus
almost has the best music and is that it
in these games
oh man I got pretty good speeding I'm in
the zone hell yeah man this music is
[ __ ] sweet oh he's just making the
noises ah there we go all the naked
people are gathered what am i doing oh
[ __ ] I'm not finished I'll come on I'm
so bad at this I obviously need to step
up in the next race alright another
cutscene
oh [ __ ] that looks pretty bad I hit my
head I think it's princess it looks
pretty serious it's true that's true
bros and girls if I don't make it tell
my wife and kids that I you should try
not to speak
conserve your strength but she I'll give
you CPR until the ambulance gets here
oh nice now please just ha ha ha ha you
like it ok some quality all those
[ __ ] I'm in last place I need a shape
up you can upgrade your body how the
[ __ ] that words I will not get into I
don't have any points all right now the
cutscene holy [ __ ]
what's that stench give me all your many
I catch you with nasty [ __ ] that's not a
scissor bro huh you Rick man spit like
toilet ever heard of a shower I think
you need one get up and put all your
money in this pig Bay where would I keep
my money anyway
Oh God what's that stuff around your
mouth Jenny I'll bet you're hitting with
esmii those flies are [ __ ] huge
here's some kind of freak aren't you
what that's it ok now ok I got a shape
up filling it I'm working it huh I'm in
the zone I'm in the zone
watch out for the homeless people just
like real life how my second place I'm
amazing ah ah I'm the greatest naked man
alive he's that he's running he's not
even on four hands for it for it I don't
know what it's called
so are those farts coming out of my ass
or how am I making those effects I don't
aren't you piece of [ __ ] no no no I hate
you
Hey oh come on fifth place well at least
not last this time God damns difficult
it's really difficult don't look at me
like that oh you were flirting I'm sorry
I'm so sorry
hello there are you waiting for someone
you wouldn't need a taxi Oh is he gonna
drive him hahaha come on jump on in I'll
give you a ride
I ain't got all day
this is the greatest story ever told the
ODC Twilight better than all of it
alright how are we doing we're in eighth
place well like my mom once said if
you're not the best then you can [ __ ]
ahead I think that's illegal
here we go what what oh how they had
stuff what well hello there baby the
cutscenes is what makes this game so
again say it's a de banane your trunks
why are you just happy to see me you
naughty girl oh it is indeed a banana
what you want one I have
uh-uh I gotta go now what the [ __ ] but
I'm never offering a banana to a girl
again I think I took a detour yeah I did
good job kids what am I where am I
supposed to go there we go
[ __ ] overzealous man I [ __ ] suck to
that one god damn what is that the same
girl that's what happens when you fall
asleep on the beach I excuse me have you
seen my sir this is not gonna end well
no okay would you mind not running in
circles around me I'm in the zone baby
what the heck are you talking about shut
up
you don't say that girls come on you can
offer them bananas
can't you see I'm driving oh hello there
my electric cousin okay not now now
they're just [ __ ] gut drugs involved
and that this is what happens a robotic
duck really unidentified human activity
prohibited
please fake backpack what please vacate
the premises you got it all wrong my
brother I'm an automobile a car a
machine just like you I think I think
you got a screw screw wrong please
vacate the premises okay final race if
only I knew where the [ __ ] to go Oh God
where the [ __ ] am I supposed to go what
are they doing why are we raising for
all these other random people are they
may be perhaps duplicates of my very
soul then why am i hurting myself
is it perhaps self-hatred of machines
with everything being machines take it
over these days and hot dogs becoming
more and more sexual yes I must be it
it's the only thing I can think of at
least who knows these days all I know is
when a man wants to race naked on the
streets or inside or on the beach or
with the homeless people that man better
race good and that man better be making
and that man maybe filling it there
should be a cosplay for this character
I'm not last I'm not gonna come last
not today [ __ ] [ __ ] throw knives at
it seven plays [ __ ] hugs Allah how am
i throwing [ __ ] - that's an ability here
we go
but why am i crying who's there
show yourself oh [ __ ] Glock Wow please
don't eat me cards don't taste very good
no new chip Glock I'm warning you
cars can be pretty dangerous don't you
know how many people die in traffic
every year good luck
glory I don't [ __ ] know this is your
last chance I'm a black belt car for
what what oh no dead people have won
high fives
[ __ ] I hate when they won high fives
their hands are really sweaty it's kind
of awkward holy [ __ ] I'm third you just
got to get that speed going bro I gotta
get that sweet running speed Oh God too
much speed what I'm second Oh God get
the speed get the speed don't high-five
them don't get distracted I don't get
where all the other people are coming I
guess I'm crazy and we finish [ __ ]
eight again ah son of a [ __ ] oh god
what now is that his nipples it's that
it's nipples that is some kinky [ __ ] man
I told you I told you no tell Marin hey
there my alien brother could you score
me some Jew
hashtag gobble gobble I'm a car and the
cars don't don't run without get her
there we go I know you know what I mean
gobble gobble okay then what about your
pal
sparkle fabulous you look like you might
have some spinny boo am i right Sparkle
oh here we go it's over honey you're
back where have you been I've been
fulfilling my destiny my dreams is
finally come true look at all this money
babe I miss you they'd reach that's
wonderful honey
now we won't have to sell the house and
maybe we can let the children go to
college even know we'll sell the house
all right I need some X occasion for my
transformation but the children you can
have him never want it escape it's dark
man this car ain't safe for kids no mo
that's for sure really okay this is the
Freak that wants to be a car a doctor
please this patients still conscious Oh
totally [ __ ] okay and nut job is a net
jab no two ways around E if you're
against it why you still going through
with the operation going through with
operation same as everyone is I do every
penny people money can't wait to give
this guy his new excels pad and that was
hot rattle what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you are
a real car I think there's a deep
meaning behind this then let's follow
your dreams and you can achieve
literally [ __ ] anything that ass
crack that [ __ ] ass crack I don't
know what else to say this is this is
fantastic
I love cactus games are so much fun I
know I know you I know what you're
thinking and I see that you're pretty
weirded out but it was fun anyway right
where does good
I think hope you boys enjoy watching I
had fun playing it leave they were like
if you're dead hits the sky recover it
today and I'll see brass in the next
month say awesome breath love you